Comic Relief asked me to make my face
funny for money for Red Nose Day this
year so here I am in the wind tunnels at
Southampton University and this this is
only a 40 mile an hour went already or
what you might find a tropical storm and
it's only going to get worse from here
now employee dynamics there's a thing
called the drag equation never mind all
those constants important bit is that
the number to square the drag force on
thee goes up with the square of the wind
speed so as we go faster there's not a
little bit more force on me we are on an
exponential
sixteen please
here up to sixty miles an hour and now
dry and lost a contact lens and I'm
thinking all I can hear this noise but
this is nothing because in 1946 now
pilot if they inject their wind tunnel
- 450
and then just stuck it in it they were
fine so surely I should be as well
dinging
that
yes
yet
that was 90 my ears of hot ah whoo okay
yeah I'm not doing nobody thank you
thank you very much
12 people from coming to vertical planet
who rigged up this wonderful system to
keep me safe which I really needed to
all the team at the University of
Southampton wind tunnel our and to you
please please please if you can read
military comm for all the details on how
you can make your face funny for money
or just donate to help out people in the
UK and across countries in Africa
hi I'm going to go and get water